Let's say k was equal to negative 5. Well, I would have the absolute value of
negative 5 is greater than negative 3. So, 5 is greater than negative 3, that's
true. What if k was negative 1? I'd have the absolute value of negative 1, which
is greater than negative 3. Well, the distance of negative 1 to zero is just
positive 1. So, this is true, too. We know any number to the right of zero will
be positive. And, in fact, the absolute value of any number is always greater
than or equal to zero. So, this is always true, it doesn't matter what k is. Any
real number would work on our number line. That was a tough question and I hope
it got you thinking. Now that we've wrapped up this lesson, try practicing a few
problems, and feel free to look back if you need to. Sometimes these concepts
can be challenging.